The US
military is striking back
after a deadly drone attack
killed an American contractor
and wounded five service members.
The Pentagon says that
an Iranian made drone
struck a base in northeast Syria.
An official telling CNN
that it was a one way drone
that intentionally crashed
into its target.
President Biden
responded with airstrikes
against groups
affiliated with Iran's Revolutionary
Guard in Syria.
What you're looking at
is social media video that appears
to show the flaming aftermath of the U.S.
strikes.
I think we're going to go to the Pentagon
right now
where we're expecting
to get a briefing on this.
Let's see if we can listen in on that.
In northeast
northeast Syria,
at approximately 1:38 p.m.
local time.
Secretary Austin, at the direction
of President Biden, authorized U.S.
Central Command
forces to conduct
precision strikes into eastern Syria
against facilities
used by groups
affiliated with Iran's
Islamic Revolutionary Guard Corps.
The airstrikes were conducted in response
to yesterday's attack,
as well
as a series of recent attacks
against coalition forces in Syria
by groups affiliated with the IRGC
In terms of air strike details, two U.S.
Air Force F-15 fighter aircraft
assigned to U.S.
Air Forces Central
and based in the CENTCOM
area of responsibility struck two IRGC
affiliated facilities
at approximately 7:40 p.m.
Eastern time or 2:40 a.m.
local
the facilities were located near Dozier
in eastern Syria,
and we're continuing to assess
the outcome of the strikes.
Initial indications are that
the facilities were destroyed
in regards
to any militant
casualties were still assessing.
These precision strikes
were intended to protect and defend U.S.
personnel And the U.S.
took proportionate and deliberate action
intended to limit
the risk of escalation
and minimize casualties.
As Secretary
Austin said in his statement,
no group will strike our troops
with impunity.
Again, Secretary Austin,
along with the Department of Defense,
offer our thoughts
and prayers
to the family
and colleagues of the American contractor
who was killed
and with those
who are wounded in the attack.
Our forces deployed in Syria
continue
to conduct their important mission
in support of the international coalition
to ensure the enduring defeat of ISIS.
Separately, Secretary Austin
and Chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
General Milley,
testified yesterday
before the House Appropriations
Subcommittee on Defense to discuss
the president's fiscal year 2024 budget.
Next week,
both leaders are scheduled to testify
before the Senate Armed
Services Committee.
In the House Armed Services Committee
on DOD's budget posture
and our Future Year's Defense Program.
Again, the secretary
and the chairman look forward
to working with Congress
to provide our service members
serving around the world
with the resources
that they need to accomplish
DOD's mission
and strengthen America's
national security
for the 21st century and beyond.
Finally, on Wednesday, Secretary
Austin unveiled
a comprehensive plan aimed
at improving the lives
of our dedicated military force
and their families.
The new plan consists
of six additional actions
that address essential
needs in education,
child care,
parental leave and career advancement.
The Department of Defense
is committed to working with Congress
and other stakeholders
to ensure the successful
implementation of these measures.
The plan directs
the implementation of the following
universal pre-kindergarten
DOD education activity, schools,
dependent care,
flexible spending accounts
for service members
promoting awareness of new military
parental leave benefits
improvements to the exceptional family
member program,
expanded spouse
eligibility for career advancement
account financial assistance,
and continuing efforts for portability
for professional licenses
for military families.
Secretary Austin
and the Department of Defense
are dedicated
to enhancing the quality of life
for our servicemen
and their families
through these new measures.
The DOD will collaborate
with Congress and state partners
to ensure the successful implementation
and ongoing support of these initiatives.
The Memorandum and additional information
can be found on the DOD website.
Just have a couple of new details
that we got
from the Pentagon press secretary.
They're specifically
that the fighter jets
that carried out this air
strike on these Iran and Iran
backed facilities in Syria were two U.S.
Air Force F-15
fighter aircraft,
and they actually struck two facilities
and we were told earlier today
that those facilities were
where Iranian proxy groups
were housing some munitions
and also using as a base
to gather intelligence.
Now, we're also told by by writer
there
that the Pentagon is still assessing
the number of militant casualties
that actually resulted
from that airstrike.
It is unclear
how many people actually died there.
However, a UK based
human rights monitoring
group says that there were at least
eight killed as a result of that U.S.
airstrike.
But look,
there were a lot of questions
here about why
that couldn't have been that that U.S.
that Iranian drone strike
could not have been prevented. Right.
Because
the point was made
that these drones don't move very quickly
and that perhaps the base
could have taken some measures
to try to take it down
before it crashed into that facility.
That was housing U.S.
personnel
and the question of the answer
that we got from the Pentagon
press secretary
there was that they're
essentially assessing what happened here.
It is his understanding
that the radar was all operating
pretty correctly
and so the question now is
what can they do better to mitigate
that potential risk in the future?
And he did say that U.S.
Central Command
is carrying out an assessment right now.
About how they can better protect U.S.
troops and personnel stationed there.
Only the
latest in
a round of attacks
from these Iranian backed groups.
Some 80 drone or rocket attacks on U.S.
troops in that region
since the beginning of 2021.
Natasha Bertrand from the Pentagon,
thank you so much.
Let's get some perspective now
from retired Brigadier
General Peter Zack.
He's a Wilson Center
global fellow at the Kennan Institute.
Sir, thank you so much for being with us.
And as we noted, that statistic.
78 drone or rocket attacks on U.S.
troops in that area since 2021.
Obviously
their Brigadier General, Pat
Ryder, asked about the security
of these facilities.
What the focus of the United States
from a security perspective
obviously is on Eastern Europe.
It's on the Pacific.
What is enough being done to protect
and fortify our assets in Syria?
In this fight
continuing fight against ISIS
I believe
that the forces on the ground
force protection
in these type of environments
now I've seen
it is paramount paramount and
and but the nature of war
the unpredictability of conflict
It's not perfect.
It's not a perfect science.
And sometimes
missiles or drones will get through.
I think that what we would know
is, is that this is an in
and when you look at the whole picture,
fairly rare.
But but it did happen.
78 attacks apparently
over the last few years
between Syria and Iraq.
And yes.
But I got to believe those
those ground commanders
whose responsibility is pay varied.
No one is force protection
for offensive operations.
And General, we know that Iran often uses
these proxy groups
to carry out these attacks,
which is what
apparently reportedly happened here.
Help us understand why they do that.
Does that allow them
to keep their hands clean, as it were?
We heard that reporter
trying to press
the general there about
if Iran was responsible
for this American death.
And he didn't quite
stop short of saying that they were
What do you make of all of that?
Well, the proxy forces, when
we hear of that,
we think of
first of all,
there is the IRGC revolution guard.
And they kind of are the, if you will,
managing and quarterbacking ever.
You've got Shia militias in there
you've got locals.
And you have also,
in fact, Dara, czar where we saw the
attack yesterday was where
sight of a very, very, very tough U.S.
and ally engagement
with Russian proxies
there and over estimated
200 including Wagner Group in 2018.
So there is a swirl of different
activities now.
The key point with the Iranian proxies
is whether they really have a swath
that goes through Syria's
sort of wild west.
South
is also risks
and it makes the Russians crazy
are getting the Israelis more involved.
And the Israelis have done
a number of these type of strikes
that we are doing now.
In against the Syrians and the Iranians
as well.
It's a complete mix of groups,
proxies, countries up in the north east.
You've got the United States,
you've got Russians, you've got Turks,
you have
the Syrians, and
you have the Kurds
and all of that is working.
And then there you have these sort of,
you know, difficult
to identify
allegiances of groups
that shift from time to time.
Right. Right.
Yeah.
A lot at play there.
Retired Brigadier General Peter Zweig,
thank you
so much for your analysis there.
We appreciate it.